um i think i lost over like 50 people
like not just through this in my
neighborhood like from chicago alone
like i knew a lot of people and like
they were young at all ages and i think
i lost over 50 people my family alone
fell victim a couple times and like i
said like from 2016 from now so i've
been taking a lot of like losses
it's hard like it's hard to breathe
sometimes mentally like physically
everything just be draining but i just
keep going just keep going i know like
the people i lost on like
they don't they don't they don't they're
gonna be proud of me one day
[Music]
everybody my name is pastor corey brooks
and i'm still here can you believe it
living on this rooftop inside this tent
for 100 days from november the 20th to
february 28th bringing attention and
awareness of the violence in chicago but
also to raise money to build a community
center on this block that's much needed
called old block the reason why it's
called o block is because it's named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed the gang started using
the o and started calling it o block we
decided we'd like to o so we're going to
call it opportunity plot and i'm so
grateful that today
i have what we do young men who i've
watched to grow and develop i watch the
ups and the downs i've seen them since
they were 9 10 11 or 12 they've been
part of our church and our programs and
i'm really excited about
what's going on in their lives but i
want to talk to them today mario
to my right and i key to my left i want
to talk to them today and help you
understand
why this center is so needed in this
community so far i want people to
understand so i want to ask a question
and the first question i want to ask is
can you just help people understand
how hard it is
growing up in this neighborhood well
like me like i'm caught up with my
environment so like
everything that could own in this like
really i just feel a victim as you know
i just got attached to it it's very hard
to go and come first like
[Music]
we had no programs we all had dreams
like everybody had dreams like be a
basketball player football player
etc like it just sometimes it just don't
work out that way like we really had a
lot of opportunities that a lot of
people have in the world so it's very
kind of hard for us but we make the best
of it
well that's right
uh yeah i think i say it's hard like um
because
like have normal kids to live a normal
life
uh we like some of us we had we had no
choice but to go into like a adult life
kind of early because of like a lot like
the violence and stuff killing like
growing up ain't growing playing at
parks and not like that like we had to
do other stuff
you know one of the things i heard you
say
is that uh mario about you know dreams
having dreams you really get to have
dreams
you didn't have the opportunities you
know can you take a moment i know it's
hard for you to talk about it
but can you just take a moment just tell
them about some of the things that
you've experienced in your own family
with the violence as far as violence is
concerned
um well i'll tell you my age well i'm 21
21 22 this year
high nine a lot of y'all i i i think i
lost over like 50 people like not just
dude this is my neighborhood like from
chicago alone like i knew a lot of
people and like they were young at all
ages and i think i lost over 50 people
my family alone feel victim a couple
times from like
i said like from 2016 from now so i've
been taking a lot of like losses
it's hard like it's hard to breathe
sometimes it's mentally like physically
everything just be draining but i just
keep going just keep going i know like
the people i lost don't like
they don't they don't they don't they're
gonna be proud of me one day yeah cause
you lost a couple uncles a brother and a
lot of my brother recently in august of
my cousins back to back 2017. my other
cousin
2020
november 6.
i wanna i'm gonna come back and i'm
gonna ask you about but you said
something about grieving my friend let's
talk about that now do you think a lot
of kids
who grew up in the neighborhood who lose
people
do they
get an opportunity to really grieve
nah like and well
right around here we don't have enough
time to breathe like i don't think it's
gonna be enough time to degree then it's
like what's around us so it'd be like
you know it's like drugs negativity it's
a lot of stuff negative we really don't
have too much positive going on over
here like only the church
probably the community center officer
mendox
do for us the church right here they
like they do what they can for us and we
like we appreciate that sometimes we
don't when i was younger i really didn't
understand like what the stuff they were
doing i was like it's lame but now as
i'm old and i understand everything i'd
be like it's everything for a reason i
appreciate everything they've done for
me yeah yeah you know one of the things
that we want to help y'all to do y'all
worked for us in the summer programs
y'all been a part of our programs and i
i love both of y'all and i'm encouraged
because even though y'all had it tough
y'all have dreams and aspirations and i
know what
and what y'all are trying to do and i'm
gonna try to help y'all to do it even
more
but if we were to get this center up
ikea
what was your job what would what you
think your job would be why
um
well i got i it's two of them so for one
um i designed i used to design clothes
so
teach like the youth how to make like
clothes and stuff like that at the end
another one is music i do music so i can
like
work in the studio and like
show like show them like how to work
stuff like that yeah you know i always
tell i keep if there's any kid who's
going to be successful if they don't
make it into clothing and entertainment
he will definitely be of great sales
because he will text you
and
he will not take no for an answer
faster you got will work he will text
you 15 times and uh that's one of the
things i like about them because they're
not asking for you to give them anything
matter of fact i taught ikea real early
i keep there's no free what no free
money no free money that's right you got
to do what work you got to work you got
to work in software they both of these
guys have an extreme work habit and
they're working hard
to change the direction of their lives
even in the tough environment he's got
music the clothes going on and mario is
uh he's got his camera here so he's into
uh media and
photography and shooting videos and so
for these guys it would will grow so
much from having a community center and
not just them but uh their friends and
their family uh will be able to develop
so in closing y'all tell us uh i'll
start with you mario and deny here with
you
what do you think this community center
will be for our community what will it
do man it'll be a tremendous like idea
there's not even our community like
people like all the community around her
not even just us like ourselves anybody
like any kid like i don't really care
like long as you
be you and be great
that's all that matters like and i want
to help you i want to help you i want to
help like with this i i don't really go
to school for this i've left everything
on my own but any knowledge i got i hope
any youth any youth that want to get
into this and why is it you know you
said something i wanna uh you said from
all the kids from all around why is that
important because a lot of people i know
what you mean when you say that but a
lot of people may not understand that
because like um i don't understand you
just because like our neighborhoods
underneath there's like a whole chicago
[ __ ] that's like you could be from
anywhere north south west suburbs like
just come just come just just come to
work just kind of have fun and have a
peace of mind because chicago is very
like it's very toxic like you know we
just got to get a peace of mind
sometimes i keep it you think it'll be
beneficial to have this center uh it'll
be beneficial to have a center because
uh it'll be more opportunities for young
like for young kids like i know like if
i was younger and the center was up i
probably i'll probably be more i want to
say like more advanced now yeah more
advanced or further ahead like i could
i'd be probably teaching young kids like
what to do and what not to do but yeah
it'll bring a lot of opportunities
and it'll keep a lot of us off the
streets
instead of being in the street you could
be in the center learn how to do
something that could uh affect you in a
good way
later in your life
well i want to tell y'all i love vote
for y'all and if nobody else got job
back i'm gonna always have y'alls back
and i'm gonna be there for you i
appreciate what y'all doing
tremendously and i can't wait
for the
job to become and how you're gonna add
to the community and how you're to have
to make america a better place so i love
y'all god bless you god bless you thank
you guys
as i always say i'll see y'all tomorrow
it's still cold out here peace
you